let's assume that we all care about
everybody that we want everyone to get
the best health care possible we just
have different ways to do it and I will
argue of course that the facts are on my
side but I'm not a doctor
question of the day listen I know we
have a lot of former Bernie supporters
here on our YouTube channel let me ask
you what's your position on Medicare for
all or at least how would you like to
see our health care system changed fixed
I think we all agree that that's that
it's flawed and I certainly don't think
that there are unreasonable proposals
from the left when they talk about
fixing and I just think that they're
based on inaccurate data so this is the
lead-in here all of the candidates
except for Joe Biden as far as I as far
as I know what's the style on the DNC
platform are supporting a
medicare-for-all or equivalent plan I
believe we do need to move in the
direction of a Medicare for All system
and we figure out how to do Medicare for
all in a way that makes sure that we're
going to get a hundred percent coverage
in this country at the lowest possible
cost for everyone I believe in a health
care system three classic guarantee okay
see that's why I don't want the lighting
to brighten this do all this let me just
tell you where I am let's look where I
am all right
well support Medicare for all now see
you see when we're in the studio and I'm
like the lights are closed and they get
really bright you look like looks like a
golfer gets Medicare for all the left
invariably they're going to point to a
few key arguments is what someone wants
to understand there so this is kind of
robot we've done we've talked about
Canadian healthcare systems in a lot of
other countries but specifically
Medicare for all they're gonna point to
a couple of main ideas that it's cheaper
first off in the long term in our
current private insurance plan that
we're going to sort of 37 trillion
versus 50 something trillion dollars and
then they said it will create better
outcomes so there's cheaper better
outcomes they base the better outcomes
generally and life expectancy infant
mortality subjective polling data that's
why they always talk about how popular
their plan is none of those claims okay
are objectively accurate so let's go to
the first claim that it would save us
money while increasing quality this is
how much of that spending in each
country is private and how much is
public here's what's amazing sorry
programs like Medicaid and Medicare and
the VA our versions of socialized
medicine it's about the same
as these other countries these countries
where the government runs the whole
health care system and then there's our
private spending it's the private
insurance system that makes health care
in America so expensive I mean first of
all I can't speak to your experience but
overall the origins of these countries
are quite high quality overall they have
higher life expectancy over in Asia mari
moist their health care system it's like
a natural religion this is they go to
subject they like their health care
system okay first off they're talking
primarily about costs there yes a lot of
things would save us money hmm like
reusing needles doesn't mean care and
this is really important because your
worldview will determine how you look at
solving the problem of healthcare in the
United States it does need to be fixed
it is a problem system but if your
worldview is primarily predicate on the
idea of cheap and that's what you see
them talking about getting it as cheap
as other countries okay from but that's
different from quality you have a world
view that requires you to examine a
system and say how can we get the best
quality health care which benefits not
only Americans but the rest of the world
so when they say that the United States
has terrible health care people who are
Medicare for all opponents yeah
proponents sorry
they usually point to two studies first
is a World Health Organization report
that it ranked the United States 37th in
health care okay here's something if you
want to understand about that that
that's that ranking system they put us
far behind social social systems not
just like Canada in the UK
we're behind Saudi Arabia and Colombia
and just Reno right neck and neck
Slovenia and Cuba so you have to ask
yourself on a second there's a wider gap
between how good Canada's system is to
the United States than the United States
and the next two on the list arkla are
Slovenia and Cuba that's because these
disproportionately way people's
subjective appalling standards yeah do
you like your health care plan which has
no bearing on the reality of the quality
of the health care this is again it
weighs more heavily how people what
people think of the health care so for
example someone who has a sack lunch
that's free from the government consists
of Wonder Bread and baloney right they
might be more satisfied with that sack
lunch than somebody who's paid for their
own where they have organic produce
meeting but you know lean meats and
fruits and vegetables they go oh you
know I paid
I paid top dollar for this and the
stakes kind of stringy we're so much but
I love my Bologna in Wonder Bread it
doesn't mean that it's a healthier lunch
right the second city they point to as a
commonwealth study that right it's a
little bit more recent they studied
eleven of the top nations as far as
healthcare and out of eleven they ranked
the united states number eleven jerks
number one with the UK okay this is
important for people like they have to
understand us yes if you're not confused
at the UK was 18th in the whu-oh study
right and they're number one in this one
what what they don't really have much to
do with health care so let's go through
this when we're talking about objective
data life expectancy also again they
point to life expectancy infant
mortality rate right so again we've gone
through the polling data we know that
poll link Cubans are as happy with their
health care in Slovenia into the United
States I don't think that's the metric
that we should use so they go to life
expectancy life expectancy isn't
directly tied to quality of health care
but also self care okay we have a much
higher obesity rates in the United
States and a much a much more diverse
demographic than say people who are
about all the same height size in a
place like Norway with the population of
Rhode Island okay now something else
World Health Organization they put a lot
of what and disability adjusted life
years what does that mean means a
completely ignores countries that keep
disabled people alive longer like the
United States infant mortality that's
usually met that's actually measured
differently across different countries
like we've talked about with violent
crime rates we actually count infant
deaths in the United States which would
not be registered in other countries
because of our higher standards of
health care so in other words countries
that don't count premature baby deaths
we actually do when you compare the two
that's an objective data they use
there's a reason they go to life
expectancy and to infant mortality and
then go to these two studies primarily
watch it when you watch pro
medicare-for-all videos out there in
segments and tell me that's not what
they do if we do some standardized
comparisons objective numbers this is
one thing it's funny from the left leg
if you look at facts okay let's look at
fact numbers states UK Canada since UK
was rated number one do they actually
offer better quality care it's not even
close okay we have Oh nine times MRI
machines of Canada for exam we like to K
look that's the empirical I can give me
my mom is going to have to wait one year
and a half for an MRI because she
ruptured a disk but that's what they
call in Canada elective along with
serious dermatology neurology that's
another we'll get to in a second I
waited 15 minutes by the way
I know I really wanted that residential
private insurance companies by the way
you're likely to dying from prostate
cancer breast cancer myriad terminal
illnesses doubled that rate is doubled
if you live in the UK New Zealand
Germany Canada compare the United Sates
and this is something today why if you
if you don't support socialized
healthcare why don't you care about the
40-something thousand people who die
without access to care well why don't
you care about the one hundred percent
increase in women who will die of breast
cancer I can play that game too
I assume that you care assume that I
care we don't want people dying we don't
want people sick we just have different
solutions to these problems if you look
at death rates specifically among
hospital patients let's go to the old
number one-ranked to UK four times as
likely to die in a number one ranked UK
hospital United States Ospital go the
flick six or seven times that compared
to United States stay home something
else yes we spend a lot more on health
care but we are the number one worldwide
country in the creation of new drugs and
publication of medical research papers
again it's not even close if we are if
we're including that in the data if
we're including the quality and new
drugs and how much we benefit the rest
of the world just like paying a
disproportionate amount into NATO you're
welcome I don't know that they're
ignoring the numbers or if it's just
given to them by AIDS because it is
interesting to me if you go home on a
second Burnie hold on a second Elizabeth
Warren hold on a second every single
leftist host out there you right away go
to life expectancy and infant mortality
but what if you go to survival rates of
terminal illnesses and cancers what if
you go to you're likely to dying in a
hospital what if you go to wait times do
they not know that I don't I'm going to
assume that their motives are altruistic
and just like Barack Obama and all these
people with the pay gap they don't have
access to Google and or Bing at a local
public library krawler Medicare is
actually more efficient than private
insurance and they specifically talk
about when you look at the percentage of
revenue spent on privatized health care
and administrative costs versus what we
would have with Medicare for all private
insurance companies in this country
spend between 12 and 18 percent on
administration costs the cost of
administering the Medicare program a
very popular program fits well for our
seniors
we can say approximately 100 billion
dollars a year just an administration
cost okay who gives a rat's ass listen
if we're just talking about numbers
we're talking about what's more
effective what's a higher quality of
care a very popular platform what does
that matter popular this is it can use
the exact same marking they've heard
from the left they go people talk about
how they don't want socialized health
care do you know what the most popular
health care system is in the United
States the mote that you know when
people are polled the VA ok IQs that
exact same argument just say it another
way to give you an idea as to how
irrelevant popularity is in the face of
quality do you know what the number one
rated most popular system and health
care insurance would be in the United
States the VA have one that's complained
about notification bell bookmark this
page on YouTube because apparently
notifications don't close everybody a
lot of us credit I said of course mug
club and on iTunes so listen it's true
okay private insurance insane
regulations government red terrorism a
lot of administrative expenses yeah it
would be disingenuous for anyone to go
out there and say if that is not the
case that being said it is an inaccurate
comparison when you're saying okay this
is the cost of private insurance and
these are the overhead costs and you
compare it to current Medicare because
you're talking about a plan that will
expand Medicare to everybody yeah couple
that looks like nor the fact that
Medicare is basically insolvent and
they're actually fewer doctors never
accepted Medicare
one in five okay refusing any new
Medicare things at all let's just assume
that that's all hunky-dory okay if you
compare the administrative expenses
Medicare okay it's not the same because
P patients over 65 they spend far more
overall on health care the
administrative cost is a much smaller
percentage spent on health care when you
expand that to everybody you're going to
have some very different numbers this is
why actually a left-leaning Plitt effect
they rated this argument half true yeah
I'm surprised about that administrative
spend in half
it's different for example than
bureaucracy in the government so
administrators getting the example in
private health care plans and insurance
they actually sometimes are spent a lot
of these costs to reduce costs overall
sometimes when you look at cost
efficiencies that requires
administrative processes and that's why
you actually have a more efficient
program with privatized health care
doesn't mean that it's the best
I mean it's it's flawless that's not
what I'm saying but again we need to
compare the numbers there needs to be
more of an apples-to-apples comparison
not apples too crazy social is
propaganda this also brings to something
else where the constants say I don't
understand why the United States the
richest country in the world is the only
country that doesn't have some kind of a
universal or socialized healthcare
system hold a second you can't
beware the wealthiest country in the
world and we're the only country that
doesn't have this kind of that's how we
got that way we're the only country in
the world that according to Berkeley 70%
of drugs and published medical research
papers come from this country and we
can't get a socialized system like
everybody else is the remaining 30%
that's all countries well yeah gene why
do you think that's the case how do you
think you got to this kind of innovation
all right another claim that they make
the United States has more uninsured
people than any other countries well oh
okay sure but the uninsured number is
mislead it's very misleading it includes
the illegal immigrants by the way who
nothing you know what they paid nothing
because if you go into an ER there's no
way to track them that's what they use
for their care it's not necessarily
preventative care yeah but if you have a
two-by-four nail to the back of your
skull from working a construction site
you know what you'll take that for free
all day long and twice on Sunday and by
the way there are a lot of people who
choose not to purchase insurance in fact
actually studies have shown that
sometimes there's an increase in total
number of uninsured people as a result
yeah of people with above-average income
just opting to go uninsured that's why
they had to in state a penalty while the
actual number of uninsured poor people
goes up so that's important to note by
the way everyone here at ladder Crowder
uninsured we use we use a health sharing
service which numbers in the seven
figures which would not be qualified as
insurance it's a health sheering problem
which actually covers you much better
than most insurance so these statistics
aren't everything that people believe
them to be the left they'll say again
these people this is very important I'll
say it's less expensive and higher
quality of care say okay tell me how its
higher quality of care and let's say the
United United Kingdom or in Canada
don't use infant mortality or life
expectancy go there's nothing exactly
there's nothing rude there absolutely is
nothing else so that's important to note
because they'll say we're right on facts
and they really cherry-pick probably the
most irrelevant facts certainly the
least comparable facts okay what else do
we have here oh another claim that's
right
medical bankruptcies do you hear this a
lot oh yeah they talk about two-thirds
of bankruptcies in the United States are
caused by this is this is parotid a lot
right now by medical bills two-thirds of
all the bankruptcies today in the United
States are due to medical issues medical
cost nope no that's just a flat no
that's just that's just enough hard
that's untrue
this isn't wheat data to make it sort of
match your narrative and that's why I
say you have to determine your worldview
first do you want to focus primarily on
quality of care and innovation and the
best healthcare do you want to focus on
giving everybody access to a crap
sandwich
studies have shown repeatedly the entire
content of medical bankruptcy it's based
on a statistical fallacy yeah okay this
assumed that bankruptcy was caused by
medical bills if the individual just so
happened to have experienced medical
debt at some point prior and how often
do you love to hear the sort of the
lesss pseudo-intellectuals now say
correlation does not equal causation
because it's the first thing they
learned in humanities it's actually true
mr. you're going on next to the Flying
Spaghetti Monster I see where you're
going with this when they look for
correlation the overwhelming majority of
people who experience significant
medical debt okay they did not declare
bankruptcy huh so you're just saying
well if someone goes if someone goes
bankrupt and they had yeah they're more
likely to have had a medical debt
incurred well absolutely but then if you
look at the vast majority of people who
did have some kind of medical that they
didn't go bankrupt this is the perfect
example of correlation does not equal
causation it's like ah if you look at
60% of serial killers they all ate Apple
Jacks
Kellogg's Ted Bundy just like just like
Gruber shitty libel for the mass
shooting we think that Applejack should
be liable for Ted Bundy and or Gacy more
money please if you go and watch Bernie
Sanders interviews you can see him at
one point they say well what about
people you know for example who might
not live the healthiest lifestyles do we
have any kind of exceptions when we're
talking about Medicare for all he goes
oh no cuz look at that point you might
have someone who's slightly chubby not
gonna play that game
yes I don't have it here he goes well
what about people who smoke we're gonna
try and get them off of that habit and
heaters yeah hold on a second what if
they don't want to right you can't say
no under Medicare fraud of course all
right the cost will skyrocket so even if
you the numbers that we have now
hopefully we've illuminated them for you
they'll only get worse if you throw
everybody on to a Medicare like plan
yeah and if so even right now if you
only look at costs it's still a wash and
here is something I think is under
important people talk about doctors okay
yeah first do no harm a doctor is not
supposed to go in and put you in the
most aggressive treatment possible a
doctor is supposed to go in and do no
harm first and see what the minimum
effective dose is for whatever treating
pain they're giving you that's what we
need to start with with our current
health care system people that are
against this idea of incremental ISM
what if incremental solutions would
actually create a world of difference
for example opening up insurance across
state lines tort reform allowing
insurance companies to create incentives
for people to be healthy and rewarding
that just like we do a car insurance
right as opposed to punishing people who
don't get insurance as opposed to
punishing insurance companies that say
you live on a diet of ring-dings Funyuns
and fried Oreos we say you have to
accept everybody and by the way we're
gonna we're not going to put caps on
premiums this is this has been a giant
kick back to the insurance industry but
I do want to say something here what
bothers me most about this and if you
want to look at people who are being
intellectually dishonest to people who
say oh these people don't even believe
what they say on the right and they
don't care if you die and they don't
have any facts they don't even believe
their own horse crap you hear people on
the Left saying this let me tell you
something I think our health care system
is broken okay I think it's something
that needs salt that needs some some
solutions thrown at it at least but I
don't think that it's unreasonable for
the left to look at our current system
and say you know what what about
Medicare for all I think it's wrong I
don't think it's unreasonable for people
to look for radical solutions in the
face of the system that we all
experience and we all realize is broken
so I'm not going to assume that all of
these people are lying to you that all
of these people are making data up or
that they're selectively omitting facts
that illuminate the picture most clearly
what I will say is I understand what
people are looking for solutions and I
don't think that it is ill-founded to
look to examples like you see with other
countries the dab
the details yeah and what really bothers
me is when these people say well why
don't you care about dead people why
don't you care about the people who are
uninsured that is one of those kinds of
arguments that stops the conversation
before it begins just like calling
somebody a racist sexist homophobic
transphobic you see this coming
exclusively from the left you don't see
the right saying hey these people want
to kill all of you they don't care about
the hundred percent increased women
dying of prostate cancer and breast
cancer we say you know what listen we
believe in highest quality of care we
believe that we have the best health
care system the world and we need to fix
it and we see that you have a different
solution and we think that it is
incorrect why don't you care about the
people who will be killed why don't you
care about the people who be sick why
don't you care about the millions upon
millions of people who will likely die
if we don't continue with the kind of
system that provides some sort of profit
incentive to create and develop new
drugs why don't you get we can all play
that game yeah
let's assume that we all care about
everybody that we want everyone to get
the best health care possible that we
just have different ways to do it and I
will argue of course that the facts are
on my side but I'm not a doctor if you
like this video subscribe or click one
of these videos playing in a box you
know what hit the notification bail
because subscriptions don't really mean
anything anymore especially if you're
not 18 or older at the very least logged
in to YouTube as a teen or older because
sometimes people are 25 but they don't
know how to use the YouTube system
properly and then you never just take
the notification Bell or you hate
yourself